SCANDAL.
THE FBI'S MEN     MISHANDLING OF
THE FBI'S MEN     MISHANDLING OT
THE FBI'S MEN     MISHANDLING OE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
THIS DEEP STATE WHICH WE'VE BEEN
WARNING ABOUT YOU IS GOING ALL
OUT.
THIS WEEK TO SEPARATE MAJOR
LEAKS FROM ROBERT MUELLER'S OFF
THE RAILS POLITICAL WITCH HUNT
IS NOW REVEALING THE SPECIAL
COUNCILS DETERMINATION TO SET A
PERJURY TRAP FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RELEASED A
LIST OF QUESTIONS THAT HE WANTS
THEM TO ANSWER, THESE QUESTIONS
ARE ALL OPEN-ENDED.
THEY ARE PATENTLY RIDICULOUS AND
DESIGNED TO TRAP THE PRESIDENT
IN PERJURY.
WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT THINK
ABOUT JAMES COMEY, WHAT DOES THE
PRESIDENT THINK ABOUT A JEFF
SESSIONS RECUSAL?
WHAT DOES HE THINK ABOUT THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL?
LET ME GET THIS STRAIGHT?
IS ROBERT MUELLER NOW THE
THOUGHT POLICE, IS IT NOW
ILLEGAL FOR THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA TO HAVE PRIVATE THOUGHTS
AMERICA TO HAVE PRIVATE THOUGHT
THOUGHTS?
ACCORDING TO
"THE WASHINGTON POST," ROBERT
MUELLER HAS THREATENED THE
PRESIDENT WITH A SUBPOENA IF HE
REFUSES TO SIT DOWN WITH AN
INTERVIEW.
DON'T FORGET THAT ROBERT MUELLER
WAS TAPPED WITH INVESTIGATING
RUSSIAN COLLUSION.
AFTER 50 WEEKS, THEY HAVE FOUND
ZERO EVIDENCE OF ANY WRONGDOING
BY THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS NOW A POLITICAL TAKEDOWN
OF THE PERSON YOU CHOSE TO LEAD
THIS COUNTRY.
SHOULD WE BE SURPRISED?
THIS INVESTIGATION IS BEING
CONDUCTED BY SOME OF THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO ARE TOTALLY
COMPLACENT IT TO USING HILLARY
CLINTON'S BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
RUSSIAN LIES -- THE UNVERIFIED
STEELE DOSSIER -- AS ACTUAL
EVIDENCE TO OBTAIN A FISA
WARRANT TO SPY ON AMERICANS IN
THE LEAD UP TO AN ELECTION.
THEY LIED AND PASSED IT OFF AS
LEGITIMATE EVIDENCE IN ORDER TO
GET A FISA WARRANT FROM A PFIZER
JUDGE TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
THAT DOSSIER WAS NEVER VERIFIED,
NEVER CORROBORATED, HAS NOW BEEN
DEBUNKED AND THEY LITERALLY
NEVER TOLD THE JUDGE THAT
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
WHOSE FINANCES SHE WAS
CONTROLLING PAID FOR IT.
IT IS OUTRAGEOUS AND THIS IS THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
HERE IS THE WHO'S WHO, WHAT DO
WE SEE?
A BUNCH OF BIG-TIME DEMOCRATIC
DONORS INCLUDING
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REFERRED TO
AS HIS PIT BULL ANDREW
WEISSMANN, HE'S GIVEN THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS TO DEMOCRATS.
WE'VE EXPOSED IS VERY AGGRESSIVE
TACTICS, THEY HAVE CAUSED
MULTIPLE OVERTURNS AND WRONGFUL
CONVICTIONS RUINING COUNTLESS
LIVES AT MERRILL LYNCH AND
ELSEWHERE.
LET'S NOT FORGET PETER STRZOK,
HE HELPED AUTHOR HILLARY
CLINTON'S EXONERATION BEFORE
OVERSEEING THE INTERVIEW MONTHS
LATER AND OF COURSE HE WAS SO
BLATANTLY BIASED HE WAS REMOVED
FROM THE INVESTIGATION OF ROBERT
MUELLER.
THEN YOU HAVE ROBERT MUELLER'S
TOP DEEP STATE DEMOCRATS THAT
REMAIN TODAY.
FORMER NEW YORK CITY MAYOR RUDY
GIULIANI WILL BE HERE TO GIVE AN
EXTENSIVE INTERVIEW TO DISCUSS
WHETHER OR NOT THE PRESIDENT
SHOULD EVER AGREE TO AN
INTERVIEW WITH THIS BAND OF
TRUMP HATING SYCOPHANTS OF
HILLARY CLINTON.
HE WILL HELP BREAK DOWN THE
BRAND-NEW CHARGES AND CHANGES ON
TRUMP'S LEGAL TEAM INCLUDING TWO
NIGHTS BREAKING NEWS.
JUST HOURS AGO THE WHITE HOUSE
ANNOUNCED THAT TY COBB WILL BE
RETIRING AT THE END OF MAY AND
POWERFUL LONGTIME WASHINGTON
ATTORNEY EMMETT FLOOD WILL JOIN
HIS LEGAL TEAM.
FIRST, WE HAVE A SHOCKING STORY
TO BRING YOU.
THIS ONGOING WITCH HUNT IS
TAKING ON REAL PEOPLE WHO HAVE
REAL LIVES AND FRANKLY ANYONE
WHO HAS EVER WORKED WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP OR ON HIS
CAMPAIGN.
FORMER TRUMP CAMPAIGN
COMMUNICATION ADVISOR MICHAEL
CAVUTO TOLD THE SENATE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE, THERE
INVESTIGATION HAD A DEVASTATING
FINANCIAL IMPACT, HE'S INCURRED
OVER $100,000 IN LEGAL BILLS AND
DURING HIS CLOSED-DOOR SESSION
HE TOLD THE SENATE WHAT AMERICA
NEEDS IS AN INVESTIGATION OF THE
INVESTIGATORS.
I WANT TO KNOW, WHO IS PAYING
FOR THE WORK IN COORDINATING
THIS ATTACK ON
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP?
I WANT TO KNOW WHO COST US SO
MUCH MONEY, WHO CRUSHED OUR
CHILDREN, WHO FORCED US OUT OF
OUR HOME ALL BECAUSE YOU LOST AN
ELECTION.
I WANT TO KNOW BECAUSE TO    GD
I WANT TO KNOW BECAUSE TO    GDO
I WANT TO KNOW BECAUSE TO    GDU
I WANT TO KNOW BECAUSE TO    GDT
I WANT TO KNOW BECAUSE TO    GDO
HELL.
YOU STILL HAVE THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA THEY ARE PUSHING YOU
FORWARD, TO AID AND ABET THE
DEEP STATE WITH HIS NONSTOP 24/7
OBSESSIVE, NEGATIVE RUSSIA,
PRUSSIA, RUSSIA, STORMY, STORMY,
STORMY COVERAGE AND IN THE
MEANTIME IGNORING EVERY MAJOR
TRUMP ACCOMPLISHMENT.
TAKE A LOOK AT SOME OF THIS
WEEK'S COVERAGE AS AN EXAMPLE.
SPEAK OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS
OUT TONIGHT WITH A LIST OF 49
QUESTIONS THAT ROBERT MUELLER WN
QUESTIONS THAT ROBERT MUELLER WS
QUESTIONS THAT ROBERT MUELLER WT
QUESTIONS THAT ROBERT MUELLER WO
QUESTIONS THAT ROBERT MUELLER WA
QUESTIONS THAT ROBERT MUELLER WK
QUESTIONS THAT ROBERT MUELLER WT
QUESTIONS THAT ROBERT MUELLER WE
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE'VE GOT A LIS
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE'VE GOT A LIT
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE'VE GOT A LIO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, WE'VE GOT A LIF
49 THINGS THAT ROBERT MUELLER
WANT TO KNOW FROM THE FLESH
INVESTIGATION.
>> YOU'RE SAYING HE GOES INTO
THE SITUATION ROOM TO GET AWAY
FROM THE CHIEFS OF STAFF?
>> I'M TOLD BY ONE FRIEND OF THE
PRESIDENT ON MORE THAN ONE
OCCASION, HE HAS BEEN CALLED BY
THE PRESIDENT FROM THE SITUATION
ROOM.
>> THIS TELLS US THAT THE
SUBJECT OF COLLUSION, DESPITE
WHAT YOU HEAR FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE, IT TELLS US THAT
ROBERT MUELLER IS NOT DONE WITH
HIS COLLUSION QUESTION.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S LAWYERS ARE
PREPARING FOR A SHOWDOWN WITH
ROBERT MUELLER.
HE COULD ISSUE A SUBPOENA
FORCING THE PRESIDENT TO APPEAR
BEFORE A GRAND JURY.
>> THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT CANNOT
CHARGE A SITTING PRESIDENT, HE
WANT TO BE A SITTING PRESIDENT
ALL HIS LIFE.
ONE DAY -- ONE GLORIOUS DAY --
HE WILL WALK OUT OF THOSE
16 ACRES AND HE WILL BE QUICKLY
CHARGED WITH A CRIME.
>> THERE IS SO MUCH EVIDENCE IN
THE PUBLIC DOMAIN OF COLLUSION,
WE DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF IT RISES
TO A CRIMINAL LEVEL BUT THERE IS
SIMPLY NO QUESTION THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WELCOMED
RUSSIA'S HELP IN SABOTAGING
HILLARY CLINTON'S CAMPAIGN.
>> IT'S WHY YOU NEED A DEEP
STATE, IT'S WHY YOU NEED PEOPLE
WHOSE COMMITMENT IS NOT TO THE
PERSON BUT TO THE PROCESS AND
THE LAW.
>> Sean: WILL FORGET ABOUT ALL
THE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S HISTORIC
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA, WERE TALKING ABOUT
DENUCLEARIZATION.
FORGET ABOUT ALL OF THESE
DEVELOPMENTS, LOOK AT WHAT THE
PRIME MINISTER OF ISRAEL DID
YESTERDAY.
THERE IS A NUCLEAR PROGRAM IN
IRAN, RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT IN
14 STATES OF THE UNITED STATES,
RECORD LOW UNEMPLOYMENT FOR
WOMEN IN THE WORKPLACE,
HISPANICS, AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
THE MEDIA WANTS YOU TO BELIEVE
THE WHITE HOUSE IS IN SHAMBLES?
NOT   NOT SO BUT YOU KNOW BETTE.
THAT'S WHY ACCORDING TO A
BRAND-NEW RASMUSSEN POLL
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A HIGHER
APPROVAL RATING IN HIS SECOND
YEAR THAN FORMER
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IF YOU'RE NOT GOOD TO HEAR THAT
IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
CHANCES ARE, YOU WILL PROBABLY
SEE THIS GUY, MICHAEL EVAN ODDI,
A LAWYER FOR STORMY DANIELS.
ACCORDING TO NEWS BUSTERS, HE
WAS ON FAKE NEWS CNN A WHOPPING
62 TIMES IN LESS THAN THREE
MONTHS.
BUT ROSENSTEIN CONTINUES TO
STONEWALL CONGRESSIONAL EFFORTS
TO DO THEIR JOB AND GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF MULTIPLE SERIOUS
ISSUES.
SPYING ON AMERICAN CITIZENS, NOT
TELLING TRUTH TO A FISA COURT.
PRESENTING UNVERIFIED,
UNCORROBORATED INFORMATION PAID
FOR BY HILLARY CLINTON AND THE
DNC.
BY A FOREIGN NATIONAL, LIES FROM
RUSSIA.
I THOUGHT RUSSIA COLLUSION AND
FOREIGN NATIONALS INFLUENCING
OUR ELECTIONS ARE BAD.
EARLIER TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
TWEETED A RATE SYSTEM THEY DON'T
WANT TO TURN OVER DOCUMENTS TO
CONGRESS, WHAT ARE THEY AFRAID
OF?
WHY SO MUCH REDACTING, WHY SUCH
UNEQUAL JUSTICE?
AT SOME POINT I WILL HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO USE THE POWERS
GRANTED THE PRESIDENCY AND GET
INVOLVED AND BREAKING TODAY,
FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED THAT SOME
LONG
LAWMAKERS HAVE NOT BEEN GIVEN
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO THE DOCUMENT.
IF YOU HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENTS FISA
PRACTICES, WHY NOT RELEASE THEM?
WERE NOT RELEASED ALL THE
DOCUMENTS, LET THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SEE IT.
IF YOU HAVE NOTHING TO HIDE IN
THE HANDLING OF THE CLINTON
INVESTIGATION, HAND OVER THE
DOCUMENTS.
NOTHING TO HIDE ON RUSSIA
COLLUSION INVESTIGATION?
HILLARY PAYING CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, FUNNELING MONEY THROUGH
A LAW FIRM, RUSH AND TO
MANIPULATE PEOPLE TO SPY ON A
TRUMP CAMPAIGN ASSOCIATE --
HANDED OVER.